I walk him to this video as somehow
listen yeah it is a bit slow this how
will the screen area here I was trying
to adjust it but okay I lost a couple of
seconds here the process are playing
against Grandmaster moskalenko who
obviously registered on the ICC when he
didn't know that the hell always will be
a GM attached though as GM GM okay you
know it's got a spanish Flag living in
Spain for a long time and he's played
the Dutch defense which is his main
opening against d 4 is even written a
book on that recent book on it the
diamond Dutch quite inspiring read all
right I'm playing on a solid set up
against it yeah I was just about to say
that he cannot play that justice he I
mean he can't play it but she's spoiling
his castling rights not sure that it is
word that he fibers of course he has
some space advantage with this Ponzi 5
an f5 but I have some pressure against
them I'm not so sure about all this
Bishop g5 or maybe night a three bishops
e-form this could be an idea also
intending long castles with check didn't
really react to it check him let's do
that if it takes Knight X it there will
be an enormous pressure on e5 and I
don't think yeah it is doing it anyway
but that feels strange to me opening up
this diagonal maybe it is not so
important but okay where'd you go i can
even go to e5 not sure it is good though
yeah while retreating does not seem
right and I wonder if you go can can do
a b5 here maybe yeah that's an
interesting move
hmm
I'm wondering about knight c6 and 96
check takes rook takes is got 95 okay so
this is complete complete nonsense okay
I need to take then ok now here it's a
matter of tempe I think I'll go rook t5
anup d 1 i'm just click on the default
he needs to spend yet another move on
uncovering the pawn now I'm not sure I'm
not sure maybe 8 7 a-6 before looks
somewhat loose maybe still maybe you
still should do it III think I don't i'd
be five after that they are not be fiber
sir yeah might be five them attacking c7
this should be it should be the right
response taking night takes he has
chances to get to in to get to d3 yeah
very quickly played if i take
yeah how to determine I mean it will be
better for white anyway it's just a
matter of precise play wii goes Bishop
b5 if i had probably not maybe Bishop b5
i take night x that's 93 and interesting
94 as the move that i'm not sure about
it takes h 2 i'm not taking a taxi 6 mm
not sure
hmm
yeah I don't know 94 Bishop h 296 is
probably not too great
I don't have hard to tell very difficult
position because of age 5 and this isn't
so clear and rock d 5 this might be okay
for me but I mean I mean okay means I
good for me but I'm not sure it sound if
achill to play Brooke f8 maybe it's
still has some coordination issues I get
to it get to f5
now this looks nice now but I checked
how to get any any progress going ok
interesting way to get counterplay check
can we get to the airport unfortunately
while I get the h-bond unless he decides
to cover it but Bishop f8 I play rook a
5 maybe our rookie ages maybe better
difficult
I can take him that's two connected
pawns no it was hanging I could just
have taken the bishop oh ok I hope I
went anyway otherwise it will haunt me
yeah I think it I promote anyway to be
honest the h-bomb will promote now he
cannot stop it really rock age to echo
drew gauge fire no no way to stop it
yeah of course rocket xe5 was still
easier to lack resign still easier to
play yeah a very tricky game I mean I
felt like I have some pressure in this
position because of my better
development but it is it is complicated
I was surprised she has some moves with
yeah I thought here this should be
should be good for white with this
Bishop opening up and he has some slight
coordination issues I don't know I don't
know about that this be five I mean
maybe this gives black an ok game I was
I was some very much reckoning with a
six here to keep my light a bit out of
play I mean after be 495 it was
obviously active i have my idea here was
aged from left g5 rook d5 and then maybe
reroute the night it's not not so clear
to me what what this position is how it
should be a shower how it should be
assessed well it cannot be too bad for
black coming
brooke d 1 probably he has some chances
to play a form if he does this now yeah
this is probably what like should do I
don't know where this this feels like I
I have something but maybe i'm not i'm
too optimistic here it so it's very very
much a matter of of precise play now the
computer wants to play look g8 and gives
light a slight advantage maybe but this
should be good for right isn't it rook
g8 jam if you look at this if i take
that's not so great because this hanks
and there's a threat winning winning the
night so i must play a slow move like
that or I don't know takes and then here
and now I'll get the poor later or this
one yeah hard to tell around here it
starts to get get nice i believe a lot
but maybe maybe he had enough counter
play as it's possible check here with
rook be aid but it's also the
possibilities yet all this is again
because the h porn is simply is simply
too too much if I get it the computer
gives why the director in here i prom
probably almost promoting the age porn
now of course this this was forcefully I
was oops simply overlooking that only
trying to cover but the palm promotes
anyway yeah an interesting game probably
he could have found he could have kept
an equal position here if he defends
better but it said strictly with limited
time thanks for watching